get more on the problems for House
Republicans and what they're facing
ahead of the midterms senior political
analyst Brit Hume joins us tonight from
Washington good evening Brett you heard
that story right now it's kind of in a
theoretical sense but what about this
forcing Ryan to get out so they could
get Democrats to vote for or against
Pelosi well that's one of those clever
sounding stratagems that you hear about
from time to time where you know you set
up this vote even though it may or may
not pass in order to force the other
guys to vote in a certain way that will
be politically disadvantageous to them
and and you know it's tried from time to
time I'm not sure on the strength of
that that you're gonna force out a
well-regarded and popular speaker before
that before he's ready to go I'd be
hesitant to believe that'll actually
happen although as we go forward here
the question of the speaker's influence
as a lame-duck is a real one which is to
say if you're the speaking you're trying
to round up votes for a particular
measure and they know you're not going
to be around and can't punish them if
they vote the other way in anyway
because he has all the power of
appointment to committees and all that
if he's leaving they might not be so
eager to go along with him so there
that's that's an issue but that's you
think about it Bret that's not really
the the problems facing the House
Republicans this time are not really
wrapped up in the personhood of the
speaker they're wrapped up in the
political gravity of the of a
president's first midterm and you know
the issues that confront the country
yeah and that's a it's a good points
classic Paul Ryan to say that I need to
tell my constituents I'm not going to be
around instead of kind of waiting until
after the election to do that but talk
about the problems facing those
Republicans I mean they've got this
immigration potential vote which is one
of the reasons that farm bill went down
that's right and and you know it's worth
remembering that this caucus had some
serious divisions within it there was
the conservative Republican caucus
before Paul Ryan's announcement of his
that he was leaving and
you know the the immigration measure
which is profoundly controversial on
which a vote may be force is is a
problem the failure of the farm bill as
you mentioned or as Peter mentioned was
a problem they're gonna have to get back
to that farm bill at some point and I
suspect they will but these are all the
kinds of problems you don't particularly
want to have as you're headed into a
midterm election particularly Brett a
midterm election which you know the
historic loss of the incumbent
president's party in a midterm first
presidents midterm is 24 seats
if 24 seats flipped this time which
would be kind of normal the Republicans
lose the house so you've got all that
going against you got the motivation
provided by the personal animus toward
Trump that so many liberal and
democratic voters feel and that adds up
to a high hill for Republicans to climb
to try to hold on to the house there's
some recent numbers that make it look a
little better than so called generic
ballot you know that's the one where you
ask would you rather vote for a democrat
or republican unnamed and in in the
forthcoming election that that used to
be you know the Republicans were like 16
points underwater in that and that is
narrowed a lot that's a good sign
president's approval rating is ticked up
that will help but it's still it's still
a huge challenge yeah uphill battle for
Republicans the right track run track is
going in the right way if if you're in
the House Republicans as well
Brit as always fascinating thank you
thank you